je pense qu'on a le casting de la
prochaine émission de star a dû regarder
on commence avec benjamin qui sort sur
ressorts de son regard garder regarder
son côté babaji benz ou encore le match
exceptionnel bravo maubeuge oui hélas il
y en a beaucoup qui disent on plaint le
rideau c'est bien normal
les shérifs fait boire aulas qui dotera
les on à géraldine regarde oui oui ma
gueule c'est ça tape oil well fédé
grande crêpe assortis à moi une grande
poêle
ouais mais contient peut voir sa taille
de guêpe c'est magnifique c'est vrai
qu'elle accueille des manifs et même à
bonn castaldi rien tard s'il vous plaît
vous croyez un dîner en commandant sur
wii merci oui allez gilles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça y est c'est jean claude dusse avait
ramené des photos de vos enfants
il ya du commutateur à aider dans leur
façon sur la photo cela la côte dont
l'arrivée à saxon saïdi c'est super
branché en fait plus et les plus et
branchés web alors là c'est toi c'est
très bon on va dire que c'est branché ou
alors gilles justement petit point hier
nous étions ou chez rogers voilà la
soirée de rogers et je vous ai vus
arriver que fatou oui à fatou été là je
me suis permis de parler à fatou je le
dis aux téléspectateurs fatou c'est l'ex
futur de gilles c'était sa meuf pendant
x années
merci on peut arrêter l'apeline là les
mecs parce que je finirais pas les
émissions
merci à eux enfin froid ici sur un
panneau à aa
je me transforme en bâtonnets ça fait
quinze fois qu'on leur dit d'arrêter la
prime mais non ils se font plaisir et de
faire un pic à plateau caillou basse
comme à la chaux-de-fonds combattre la
crise
[Applaudissements]
et tous ses copains et les pots cassés
mois valery hache le ballon le dit aux
téléspectateurs
je vous lis l'ac thann moon a lâché 1 je
vous le dis voilà moi je dis les choses
hier j'ai dira pas tout qu'est ce qu'il
fait avec jean et elle me dit je la
compare la compagne pour l'instant donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe d'abord elle
était enchantée de venir bien sûr ce que
c'était une noble cause pour le genre et
puis vous savez qu'elle vous aime bien
donc c'est vrai je suis content de voir
cyril elle est venu dire bonjour tout de
suite elle est contente de voir l'équipe
donc elle était très contente
vraiment j'avais vu le sait alors vous
êtes grosses sommes on est rentrés
ensemble et y'a pas nos mamans non non
non non mais il va pas dans ça tout
pourquoi qui est là et non à coadout
vous avez fait tout à fat où j'ai rien
fait du tout est ce qu il a fait toi pas
tout donc je pense que quoi qu'il arrive
faudra du temps un je le disais pourquoi
today y en a abba ben hilli d'édition
n'ont une idée de commerce à jean blanc
elle ouvre à du toilettage pour chiens
l'appel rafa tout a marché
j'aime bien j'ai pensé à ça ce week-end
bien ça les gars je vais leur parler toi
oui
pas tout à fait quand elle vous a dit
j'accompagne oui j'avais cherché alors
les plus lourds ou socialement loin elle
m'a dit je n'ai pas l'endroit pour en
parler elle m'a dit viens à la maison ce
soit 1 3 heures du matin et tu verras
comme on dit gilles et moi j'y vais je
ne veux pas voir ça me regarde notre vie
donc pour l'instant il n'y a pas c'est
un ans et on discute on dit ce qu'accor
d'accord oui j'ai une info
supplémentaire
merci voilà la journaliste
personnellement quand même dit que la
porte était grande ouverte et que gilles
avait les clés étoiles à bruay grande
ouverte pour sortir j'ai vécu je les ai
vus dans les escaliers se tenait la main
s'il sait si ça ils vont pas se tenir le
pied contient pas la main ces faits
divers à brochon alors c'est vrai bravo
benjamin là où il faut on a là on a la
journaliste et le détective à la haye
avait il y avait beaucoup de tendresse
oui et en fait honnêtement cyril ça
faisait longtemps que j'avais pas vu
aussi souriante rayonnante elle était
heureuse eu comme j'étais content quand
j'ai vu mais oui oui oui j'ai vu le
plaisir partagé
et elle souriait elle était heureuse
d'être là vraiment sincèrement et ya
isabelle je voudrais dire bravo il
aggrave aulas que isabelle qui a pris
quelque chose qui achetait quelque chose
aux enchères hier et je voudrais dire
aussi bravo à jean mi bravo les cherry
pour la soirée de rogers ils ont acheté
de trucs aux enchères qui défilent aussi
bravo à vous vous avez été formidables
côté
calais valérie bénaïm regard des veline
kaboul benhaim tu tournes notre gueule
genre t'es du porteur poil dalle alors
figure soit égaré vous pardonner je me
suis levé à faut vraiment qu'il ya des
mecs derrière tout ça je me suis levé
exprès à 6h30 du matin pour que la
piscine soit vide et c'est chez soi sur
la faute unanime et hamacs week-end 0-1
et embrasse très fines lamelles sur
l'année grâce à pas le ben oui c'est
donc moi je suis le fait exprès bas
voyez bien d'ailleurs il n'ya pas le
soleil levé que c'est bien voulez que je
vous dise ouais ben haim est excitant ah
ouais bon je lui ai même en poils mais
mon poêle à oui on aimerait bien sortir
sa frite alors là il y en a une qui a
joué le jeu à fond
c'est isabelle regarder bravo bravo avec
les regrets elle a carrément
magnifique
c'est magnifique frappe au dessus dû
applaudir sa continuelle et chérie ça va
ça va la poursuivre longtemps un visage
va beaucoup en parler mais une fois de
plus tu as joué le jeu ma chérie menée
par maxime ata foot et c'est ce que
dépense n'est pas fou tu es tu l'a
envoyé comme sa maxime son foot à
jean-yves à côté de moi je les vois
l'iphone qu'il a ça tu étais pas il est
à côté dans une cache rien maxime il me
cache rien la presse jacques tissot
maxime brighelli maxime d'hooghe gaxie
la dhuys en tout cas rien dans maxim est
venu chez what
non mais hier soir hier la soirée ainsi
la soirée
non j'avais passé la photo mme may foot
oui évidemment
c'est fou ça mais la vue des flouté
isabella oui mais le foot est donc
maxima but est simple un peu ah oui
alors série l'otan jésus c'était comme
ça déjà
merci en tout cas merci hein
en bonus vous venez avec jean michel
maire qui a tout donné
il en a même fait une vidéo regardée au
chant un pas du tout gênée par la nudité
et y en a une qui l'a pas fait c'est
kelly et kelly bien entendu vous aurez
un gage en plus pour benoît il ajouté
j'ai pas de poule et on va vous trouver
quelque chose vous inquiétez pas vous
allez faire quelque chose d'ici demain
c'est obligatoire
1 je me demande s'ils n'avaient pas
partir à poil tout de suite dans la rue
ces martyrs garde
[Applaudissements]
on est très contents les gens de
l'appartement de jean michel drevet
vous qui êtes très fier de votre corps
vous n'avez pas été tenté de le faire
aussi un goûter jeux j'ai gagné les
matches contre vous gagneriez gage
peut-être en fin de semaine je ferai
tout ce que vous voudrez non mais pour
l'instant il ya 1 0 pour moi on fera les
comptes lundi
jeudi pour l'instant à mon avis vous
allez encore être à poil mais là je les
réduire au rang des cas sans briller